pay attention to the following clip from
Avengers Infinity war did you see it
let's show you again be very careful
what your kids are watching do not just
brush your offers it's just a movie
what's the har no this is
shik as we watch what is unfolding today
in razza we have to understand that
opposition is counting on us to lose
attention to become fatigued and to move
on with the new cycle and just as we
can't allow them to dictate our
attention we also can't allow them to
dictate the pace of our solidarity and
part of that solidarity is going to be
there to rebuild RZA shortterm long-term
I am proud to give my support my word of
support to trusted brothers and sisters
in the United Kingdom that have started
a walk that have started an endowment to
make sure insh tal that we're there for
the long
run guys hope you guys are well insh so
this video clip brothers and sisters
that was sent to me on Instagram is of
the Avengers and the movie Infinity War
now somebody spotted this and Subhan
Allah if you watch carefully which which
we're going to watch for ourself inshah
um they are writing in Arabic that Allah
is not the Dominion in a nutsh show
Allah is not the king let's watch for
ourselves in and see what is let's watch
for ourselves inshah and see for our
sisters was this an accident or
premeditated pay attention to the
following clip from Avengers Infinity
war did you see it let's show you again
if you pay attention to the background
there is some Arabic writing on the
Planet Titan now I do not want to repeat
what these words mean but I will explain
so you can understand the words
translate to Allah is not
Dominion Satan makes his intentions
clear so guys you saw that for yourself
Subhan Allah as you can see why would
the Marvel movie out of all movies for
that matter decide to name a planet
behind uh the scene of this creature
whatever the hell it is yeah Subhan
Allah and write Allah is not the king do
you really think these things are
coincidences do you think they're just
like oh let's just find a little random
Arabic word Subhan Allah where where
where who which Muslim would ever write
Allah is not the king this is something
that you have to go it's premeditated
it's planned it's you know it's put in
there on purpose subliminally okay it's
very simple brother and sisters we
believe in shaitan we need to understand
that we believe in the Unseen we believe
that Shayan exists evil exists therefore
these things are not a coincidence and I
won't be surprised if there is some
Zionist scumbag in behind the scenes you
know most of them you know are
controlling Hollywood let's be honest
with most them are Zionist yes and they
went there and thought to theel you know
what yes we're going to write this it's
subliminal just imagine a Marvel movie
that your kids watch brother and sisters
and this subliminal message is there now
brothers and sisters I am guilty of this
with my children as well sometimes
giving them the iPad giving them the and
and I try my best to incorporate in my
household to my wife to the best of my
ability to stop giving them the phone
always watching TV always having iPads
try to incorporate for them to be
reading a tablet that the battery never
runs out I don't know if you guys have
heard of this you can't buy on Amazon
you can't buy it anywhere actually you
can buy an Amazon it's a book brother
sisters a book that the battery doesn't
die out it doesn't affect
your thank you very much lean I think I
broke my left shoulder a book as you can
see guys it doesn't need charge it
doesn't affect your eyes it doesn't have
blue light on so brothers and sisters in
and has many other Ripple effects this
doesn't need a charge get your kid
inshallah to start reading books proes I
think it's a very very important
reminder which was actually given by
zishan to myself by the way it was not
from me uh Subhan Allah so that's number
one number two brother and sisters you
need to understand Allah subh T says in
the Quran which is the um Allah in Quran
so did you think that we created you for
nothing and that you will not be brought
back to us so high above is Allah the
King the true there is no God but he the
lord of the noble throne and whoever
invokes another God with Allah while he
has no proof for it his Reckoning is
only with his Lord surely the infidels
will never achieve success brothers and
sisters when we study toed the third
thing that we study is
uh yes brother and SS which is what
names and attributes what these
individuals are doing is trying to strip
Allah subhana wa tala of that title by
saying he is not the Dominion he is not
the king and in brother and sisters what
makes Islam so unique is that we affirm
Allah is the sustainer and the provider
he's the one who created the heavens and
the Earth and he provides for us and he
sustains Us number
two yes that was which is what we single
out Allah in worship he is the king of
all Kings brother and sisters he is the
one that deserves worship and we worship
him alone and when it comes to his names
and attributes we do not give the name
of a creation by saying for example
attributes are saying Allah slept or
Allah was tired do you get what I'm
trying to say and neither do we take the
titles of Allah subhana wa tala by
saying he's not the all knowing Subhan
Allah brothers and sisters yeah which
the Christians give to Jesus they say he
is God but he did not know the a so we
neg get these things brother sisters
this is what makes Islam Islam and toed
toed brother sisters be very careful
what your kids watch these days brother
sister things are so dangerous you don't
need to worry about this in a book okay
when you buy a book sisters you are in
control there are no subliminal messages
which they can be but what I'm saying is
you can choose which books to buy for
them inshallah and brothers and sisters
it will inshallah help them because you
need to understand these are the future
generation if we subliminal like a lot
of psychologists say be
conscious you guys know I speak very
fast so I'm making a very valid point if
I'm speaking slow please listen
carefully be conscious of the
unconscious mind be conscious of the
unconscious mind we have an unconscious
mind that we do things we do not realize
and these are based on things that you
watch not only that there are things
where there are men male or female
private parts in in Disney movies that
Subhan Allah i' I've heard so brothers
and sisters be very careful what your
kids are watching do not just brush your
offers it's just the movie what's the
har no this is shik they are they are
associating by saying he's not the king
who's the king then Subhan Allah we know
Allah subhana wa tal is the one and only
true king of all Kings he is the one
that deserves our worship brother and
sisters like we
say you alone we worship and you alone
we ask for help so Marvel movie whoever
the hell you guys are our fight with the
Shan will inshallah carry on to many
generations will come inshallah brothers
and sisters watch out do not watch
Marvel movies Subhan Allah God knows
what God knows what other subliminal
messages are in there Allah subhana wa
tala is the king of all Kings inshallah
and we will testify that to the day with
inshallah and those who reject that will
enter the fire inshah